c'est un des enjeux majeurs liés à
l'évolution des technologies la
cybersécurité avec la protection des
données
une activité dans laquelle est engagé le
groupe atos un sujet important dans son
développement de l'ordinateur quantique
sur son site des clayes-sous-bois ses
ordinateurs de ses ordinateurs
quantiques vont permettre de décrypter
des algorithmes des algorithmes
cryptographiques qui aujourd'hui ne
peuvent pas être attaqué par des
ordinateurs classiques simplement parce
que l'ordinateur quantique accélère très
fortement les calculs atos l'un des
acteurs de la cybersécurité à saint
quentin en yvelines à côté d'airbus ou
de thales également présente des
startups comme roxy box créé en 2014
avec une croissance moyenne de 100 % par
an puis numerix une pme du territoire
engager toutes les deux dans ce secteur
notre ambition effectivement d'avoir un
système qui va permettre que les données
qui sont sauvegardés les systèmes qui
sont sauvegardés sont complètement
invisible à ces attaques et
conséquemment suite à une attaque très
rapidement en deux clics on va être
capable de redémarrer les systèmes
infectés que nous avons l'intention est
l'objectif de mettre en place une une
formation dans le domaine de la
cybersécurité et de plus loin ce sera
effectivement management de la
cybersécurité et on commence
effectivement donc ces formations-là
notamment les fondements de la cie la
sécurité mais aussi la cryptologie d'ici
la fin d'année
cette matinée avait un objectif c'est de
réunir toute la filière tout
l'écosystème en matière de cybersécurité
qui est une filière qui créent des
emplois qui est une filière d'avenir
essentiel pour la souveraineté aussi et
bien de notre pays ici à saint quentin
qui est notre territoire qui est un
territoire bien positionné en matière de
cybersécurité en france près de 8
entreprises sur dix sont touchés par des
cyberattaques 43 % de ces attaques
visent les petites et moyennes
entreprises